cosa ti porta qui oggi cara problemi di
stomaco stomaco stomaco stomaco ce l'ho
lui cara no no no no no non è l'origano
che ti metti sulla caprese quando tu
varchi la soglia di questo posto devi
iniziare a guardare le cose da un'altra
prospettiva 13 cucchiai di origano una
puntina di Artiglio del diavolo una
spolverata di ginco Boba fidati lo
mettevo nel biberone alla mia bambina
quando aveva le colichette passava tutto
Adesso sono cresciute guardale guardale
come sono venute su bene La piccola si
chiama echina la Grande citronella come
la nonna Scusa se mi permetto posso sì
dobbiamo eliminar energie negative
Tesoro sei piena Rasa Rasa Palo Santo
shamani INCA indigeni delle Ande si
parla di antichità ma non è finita qui
la salvia Bianca veniva offerta dagli
indigeni americani al bisonte bianco non
lo so cos'era era qualcosa di immenso
ricordati che se dai fuoco alla casa il
fuoco simboleggia passione grinta
energia pura sono €150 cara se hai
bisogno di qualsiasi informazione chiama
pure qui Vedi direttamente di me Sono
passi Flora valeriana namaste